j'accueille robert hossein
bonsoir bonsoir ça bah oui sortie de
scène la wii s'est bien passé j'espère
donc vous reprenez huit clos de jean
paul sartre à marigny dans une mise en
scène de vous savez comment on fait
robert avec les mains comme ça merci
donc avec vous dans le rôle de garcin
natacha amal dans le rôle d'inès mélanie
page dans le rôle des stèles
alors c'est une pièce que vous aviez
déjà monté en l'an 2000 quand vous avez
repris le théâtre marigny c'est un peu
votre pièce fétiche huis clos mouzoun
beaucoup parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour s'arrêter pour la
pièce que je trouve intemporel c'est une
des pièces qui n'a pas vieilli sur la
piste d'un visionnaire est qui et qui
est valable il ya aujourd'hui demain
j'ai 17 ans en 44 moment de la création
vous avez joué au début de votre
carrière
alors effectivement quand on parle de
huis clos on pense tous à l'enfer c'est
les autres n'est-ce pas titoff
bien sûr vous voyez sur est en fait
c'est pas les autres qui sont infernaux
faut le dire parce que les gens
comprennent souvent mal la formule c'est
le regard des autres ces jugements décès
ça c'est ce que disait ça d'ailleurs
cette extraordinaire il a écrit cette
pièce pour trois de ses amis et comme il
les estimait beaucoup il craignait qu'à
déroulent soit plus important qu'un
autre
il a décidé de les enfermer justement en
enfer pour que personne ne puisse sortir
de scène alors à saint germain dans les
années 40 mardi côtoyaient sartre oui
vous ai côtoyé genèse et que je vais les
vaillantes ou grande époque mais assez
l'époque de boris viande en 18 ans il
aimait chez les lutteurs le club du
vieux colombier de la rue saint benoît
alors c'était à vannes alors vous allez
pas oublier un petit peu de vos charmes
vous étiez pas bon c'est pas rigolo
les six balles gigolo macro mais malgré
tout quand même vous étiez une espèce
comme vous dites d'ailleurs de goujat
bien-aimée quads et des femmes vous
aimez bien mais c'est vrai que jeune
déjà vous alliez frapper à la porte des
loges des comédiennes en leur déclarant
votre flamme vous alliez voir comme ça
des ailes darrieux blanchette brunoy
michel alpha edwige feuillère michel
maure gants
vous dites comme ça vous arriviez disait
madame je suis amoureux de vous et des
fois ça marchait il y en a qui vous
ramener chez elle parce que c'était un
caméra qui m'avait dit situé à plus ou
moins amoureux fait comme moi je vais
aux folies bergère est pratiquement tous
les soirs je me mets derrière
j'essaie de délicatement passer ma main
sur le dos d'une jeune femme genre soit
8 gif sur 10 mais deux fois ça marche
voilà alors en 55 vous réalisez votre
premier film qui à un titre d'ailleurs
très sartrien qui serait enfin il avoue
rencontrer marina vlady vous faites
jouer dans le film vous êtes tombé très
amoureux de marina vlady elle vous dit
que vous n'êtes pas son genre verra mais
pour l'avoir marina vlady
compétitionnera mais elle m'avait
proposé de vider l'océan avec une
cuillère en faisant city arrive ne tête
rousse et vous avez sûrement dû déplacer
et donc voilà quelques mois plus tard
vous l'épousé l'apogée pour vous avec
les femmes ça a été en génique c'est et
joffrey de peyrac
non c'est parce que j'avais tour des
j'ai eu la chance et la joie des bougies
de bardos le repos du guerrier
lorsqu'après le producteur m'a donné
l'autre contrat il m'a dit maintenant
vous me donnez un film il m'a dit que
j'allais faire peyrac et j'ai refusé en
lui disant que ça m'intéressait pas du
tout pour une fois que je pouvais jouer
un match aux dents avec brigitte bardot
jeudi à un type cicatriser bossu tordus
qui boite physique pas mes emplois il
m'a dit c'est ça ou le procès j'ai
accepté j'ai demandé simplement
l'autorisation de choisir ma cicatrice
mon costume et magna de deux boîtes de
bois